in the last chapter of my forthcoming
happiness book I have a quote by Victor
Frankel where he basically says you know
don't pursue directly success it is
something that comes as a consequence
and I use that because I argue that I
completely analogize that to to
happiness and hence I agree with Jordan
Happiness should be something that
results from you having adopted the
right uh mindsets the right decisions
and so I think you mentioned purpose and
meaning so in one of the chapters where
I talk about the two decisions that are
most likely to impart either great
amount of misery or great amount of
Happiness to you I say that the choice
of spouse that you choose
and the choice of profession that you
choose are the ones that are going to do
that either make you more miserable or
or happier
foreign
Rubin and joining me today is an
evolutionary behavioral scientist an
author of the brand new book The sad
truth about happiness and possibly just
possibly the most time returning Reuben
report guest my old friend Gad said
welcome back to the Reuben report oh
Dave I'm so happy to be back although
I'm a bit dismayed that it's not sure
whether I'm the most
please check and get back to me with
those stats dad my team I have a very
crack team here they're working overtime
to try to figure this out right now we
know that it is either you Jordan
Peterson or Douglas Murray there's a
little uh murkiness around Jordan
because I've done so many other things
with him that we sometimes count as
shows sometimes we don't but I will say
without question you were the first ever
guest on the Reuben report the first
time I ever did a full one-on-one in
studio sit down with another human being
back in September of 2015. it was a test
show but I counted as the first show it
was with Gad said eight years ago I
can't believe it my goodness man we were
kids you remember that we were kids and
I was fatter
and fear right before we connected uh
that you're half the man you used to be
but I guess that's a little why don't we
start with that uh because mostly people
tune in to you on this show to talk
about your tan and what you've been
doing lately to get that beautiful
Lebanese bronze uh but also you've lost
a bunch of weight you're always a happy
guy that's what that's what the book is
about and by the way I should note I
have the uncorrected proof here so I
don't know if you added any additional
happiness
or anything well this is the the final
one so it's a bit more glossy looking
yeah but talk to me about how the tan
and the weight loss are connected to
this whole thing and then we'll get on
to everything else and that's that's a
wonderful way to start the conversation
so the tan comes from my having just
returned from uh Portugal uh with my
family uh and so there's all kinds of
Happiness to unpack there number one
having a great spouse with whom you can
uh spend your life with uh I actually
discussed this in quite a bit of detail
in the book uh so and you've met her you
know on on numerous occasions
having great children I know that you
recently became a double twice father so
you must now finally understand what it
means to have this unconditional
obsessive obsessive love for those
carrying your genes into the Next
Generation uh and regarding the weight I
actually discussed that in the book when
I'm discussing uh the importance of
persistence resilience there's nothing
magical about how I lost about 86 I
think from my heaviest weight to my
lightest
I dropped 86 pounds and I did it by
repeatedly making the right decision on
a daily basis right so it's Little Steps
uh what is the secret well number one I
walk between 15 to 20 000 steps a day
now the walking could be on a stationary
bike it could be an elliptical it could
be literally walking outside but I have
my phone with me so that it's tracking
every single step that I take all day no
matter how I feel I have to reach 15 to
20 000 steps but of course as you and
probably most of your listeners know
much of your weight loss or weight
maintenance comes from what goes into
this gluttonous hole it's about 90 of
your weight loss is going to come from
what you eat and so what I try to do
basically is
hover around 15 to 1700 calories a day
the way that I know that is because my
lovely spouse and a very gestapo
nazi-like way keeps track of every
single thing that goes into my mouth and
so at the end of the day she'll tell me
you know you're at 1638 calories don't
have any more snacks and so by being uh
you know res you know having to risk uh
you know be accountable to number one my
steps number two to my daily calories
bit by bit I woke up one day 18 months
later as you said half the man that I
was and so that there's no secret it's
just hard work and persistence so
obviously we'll dive into a bunch of the
the bullet points of the book and all
that but I have to say since we've been
doing this since 2018 a lot has changed
in this world politically culturally
everything else you you are still in
Canada I know we I've been trying to get
you to these great United States
preferably to the free state of Florida
for quite some time hasn't happened just
yet
um but I thought maybe we could talk a
little bit about just how how much sort
of culturally and socially has changed
and that in many ways these were the
exact things that we were talking about
back in 2015 and the years since whether
you look now at the gender stuff where
the neo-racism stuff all the woke stuff
that everyone talks about a lot of us I
would say me you Jordan Douglas who I
mentioned before we were sort of all
warning about a lot of these things I
can't tell how happy should it make me
that we were we were right about this
stuff well it of course it's it's Mr
happiness that's right it's natural to
have a bit of an ego in that you you
don't want to be gleeful but you are the
person and when I say you meaning all
the people that you just mentioned we
are sitting in the back of the room with
our hands folded saying hey I told you
so not that you wish to be gleeful about
that but uh you know it is frankly
frustrating because had many people been
you know hated our warnings maybe we
wouldn't have gone down the abyss of
infinite lunacy the extent that we have
uh but look life is auto corrective
science is auto corrective bad ideas
come and go and so
taking the point that we mentioned
earlier about persistence in weight loss
we remain persistent we remain committed
to spreading good ideas and hopefully
there'll be in auto correction and these
ridiculous ideas will be in the Dustbin
of History
I often ask you privately but I'll ask
you publicly also what what does keep
you in Canada at this point I ask this
to basically all my Canadian uh guests
because obviously Canada has a lot of
problems and you've had Frozen bank
accounts not you personally as far as I
know but I mean there's been frozen bank
accounts the onslaught against free
speech about against the ability for
people to go to church Trudeau's
government for some reason still
continues to this day I mean what really
keeps a guy like you that cares so
deeply about these issues you're now
living in a place that in many ways is
as far as a Western Country completely
at odds with uh with what I know your
beliefs are yeah no thank you for that
question uh it's even worse in Quebec
than the rest of Canada right you can be
in Alberta and it's slightly or or a lot
more you know less socialist than than
Quebec so I'm truly in the worst
possible place what keeps me there Frank
I mean there are two things number one a
lot many of the family members of both
my wife and I are in Montreal and since
we have young children that's always
something that's going to make it more
difficult to extricate yourself from you
know the extended family but frankly
probably the number not probably
definitely the number one reason is that
I'm a tenured professor right and so in
Academia it takes you know it's very
very difficult to get a job as a
professor you could be the most
accomplished Professor for you to move
from one place to another
requires that you know a million things
fall into place right now when you're
tenured
that's the ultimate you know protection
right I mean the only thing that has
allowed me to survive you know the fact
that I take the positions that I do is
precisely the protection of tenure and
so to now walk away from that without
having the security of a tenured
professorship elsewhere is very very
difficult to do right so you know I've
always talked about uh what would be the
amount of money that would permit me to
have an exit strategy out of Quebec and
again I think that if we didn't have
young children then that amount of money
would be much lesser in order to exit so
because of having young children because
we have a lot of family in Montreal and
because I'm a tenured professor that's
what's kept me here but believe me even
later today it might interest you to
know without giving too many details I
am speaking to a
college or university in Florida
precisely to see if there's a way for me
to be closer to you so let's well I am
very very happy to hear that do you
think Canada has hit Peak lunacy yet or
do you sense that it's still going to
get worse because I'm seeing some level
of pushback now not just from you but
even some of the truckers and I had
Tamara Lee Sean who was one of the lead
trucker people like there is a new
pushback against some of the craziness I
think so I do see that the the the
promulgators of the parasitic ideas are
still hanging in and if if anything
they're only getting worse I think where
the Improvement that you are mentioning
is coming from is the response to the
lunacy and so you are right that a
greater number of voices in all sorts of
settings are starting to find their
spines find their testicular fortitude
so that you know makes you feel good
that there's but it moves so slowly
right it has taken you know that many of
the people that you've been talking
about you know a decade two decades I
mean especially since I'm in in the
academic ecosystem I've been warning
about these parasitic ideas for several
decades let alone 2014 and 15. remember
that my area of scientific inquiry is
applying evolutionary biology and
evolutionary psychology and
understanding human behavior and so a
lot of these parasitic ideas the
rejection of biology the rejection of
sex differences existed within my
scientific Pursuit before they had
entered the culture wars and so yes
there is Improvement but there's a lot
more work to be done yeah absolutely all
right now to the book because happiness
is a big topic and I was thinking as I
was flipping through it before there's
something interesting about writing a
book about happiness because it puts a
lot of pressure on the author sort of
the way I always felt that Jordan was
under a lot of pressure by writing 12
rules for life because man if he broke
one of those rules then why would you
want to buy this book and to Jordan's
credit people always ask me I never saw
him break a rule I really in all the
years I've known him I've never seen him
do it but at a happiness level to say
I'm going to be the guy that's going to
tell people to to how to be happy it's a
lot of pressure now I know I know you
very well and you're happy and smiley
and you love your wife and your kids and
all that stuff but how much work in a
life that's been fairly uh complex and
had its share of tragedy actually was it
to to get to that place and then to say
oh I can be a expert on this well thank
you that's a fantastic question so maybe
I'll start by explaining how I came to
write a book on happiness if you would
have asked me five years ago was that
within my radar I would have said no
what led me to her and I actually
discussed this in the first chapter of
the book is that I noticed that in my
social engagements some of the most
powerful responses that I would receive
from people is when I offered some
prescriptive advice right typically I
operate as a as a behavioral scientist I
operate in descriptive world I just
describe why do people do what they do
without saying this is what you should
do that was very much more the the
purview of as you mentioned Jordan
Peterson and also especially because
he's a clinical psychologist so he's
helping people don't do this pattern
follow this pattern right but then when
I noticed how much people would respond
favorably to
you know some you know 100 character
thing that I put up on Twitter and then
they're saying my God that's changed my
life and I would say really that struck
me as a rather banal obvious point to
make and then so people would write to
me and say you always even though you're
dealing with such serious issues you
always seem to be playful and there's
always a twinkle in your eye and you're
always happy what's the secret professor
and so I said you know what why don't I
think because parasitic mind the
previous book was about negative mindset
parasitic ideas that infect your brain I
thought well why don't I now complete
the story and talk about you know
winning mindsets optimal choices that
you can make but to your point though I
had the epistemic humility hopefully in
writing this book not to guarantee you
or if you implement these I guarantee
you'll be happy all I can say is that
statistically speaking if you were to
implement these or adopt these mindsets
it increases the probability of you
being happy let me ask you guys that
yeah well as a man of science as you
know I have two young boys here and
they're only two months apart but Justin
who's my oldest this kid came out into
this world with a smile on his face and
a zest for life and I'm gonna get
everything and Luke came out much more
I'ma look you up and down I'm gonna
figure out what's going on here think
about it but and to me so much of that
now spending so much time with them as I
do seems hardwired the the the either
not I don't want to say desire for
happiness but the predetermination or
something that would lead someone to be
just smiling all the time versus someone
that runs a little bit cooler uh how do
you factor that into you know what makes
someone happy question uh about 50 of
differences across people in terms of
their happiness stems from genes so at
at First Class you might say oh so it's
hardwired in my genes no because that
means there's 50 percent up for grabs so
Justin is born with the sunnier
disposition so in a sense
a climbing mouth happiness he's he's
starting off ahead but if he then with
the 50 that's left up for grabs if he
then adopts
mindsets and takes decisions throughout
his life that don't optimize happiness
it's very likely is you're it's Luke the
second one yeah it's very well possible
that Luke can you know overshoot him in
happiness so I say that right off the
bat it's it's obviously clear that some
of us wake up in the morning with a
completely different daily disposition
than someone who's more Sullen and so on
but again that's good news 50 percent is
up for you to change and so it's exactly
what you're saying yes it's funny
because even watching them it took Luke
a little bit longer to start crawling
and then the second he started crawling
I noticed he started smiling more and it
was almost as if he wasn't that happy
because he was kind of stuck and then
once he started moving then he allowed a
little happiness to get in there but
let's talk about since we've mentioned
Jordan a couple times one of the things
that he talks a lot about that I think
uh has helped a lot of people is that
your goal shouldn't be happiness your
goal should be purpose for first off you
do I I sense you agree with that but can
you explain how do you how do you meld
those things and what you see is the
difference of those things yeah so in in
the last chapter of my forthcoming
happiness book I have a quote by Victor
Frankel where he basically says you know
don't pursue directly success it is
something that comes as a consequence
and I use that because I argue that I
completely analogize that to to
happiness and hence I agree with Jordan
Happiness should be something that
results from you having adopted the
right uh mindsets the right decisions
and so I think you mentioned purpose and
meaning so in one of the chapters where
I talk about the two decisions that are
most likely to impart either great
amount of misery or great amount of
Happiness to you I say that the choice
of spouse that you choose
and the choice of profession that you
choose are the ones that are going to do
that either make you more miserable or
or happier and through Jordan's point
about purpose uh
I wake up every day you know with
terrific gleeful I'm rubbing my hands
together in anticipation because my job
brings me great uh purpose and meaning
today I'm gonna talk with Dave Rubin
later I'm gonna meet a graduate student
then I'm gonna speak to a college in
Florida then I'm gonna put up a sad
truth I'm constantly in creative mode so
that's actually something I talk about
in the book that the the surest way to
find purpose and meaning irrespective of
which profession you follow is to
instantiate your creative impulse now
that's a very broad statement because I
could be a chef and be creative I could
be an architect I could be a stand-up
comic creating new material I could be a
podcaster I could be an author and a
professor but all other things equal if
you immerse yourself in the creative
impulse you're more likely to find
purpose and meaning very few insurance
adjusters probably wake up and say
thank God I'm an insurance adjuster I
find such purpose and meaning doing that
so what do you do for that person so for
the person that's an insurance adjuster
that's watching this right now that it's
it's a it's a mundane activity let's say
they might have the great spouse they
might be making a decent living but the
day-to-day thing and I'm sure there are
some insurance adjusters who absolutely
freaking love it but whatever that job
is that whatever we're talking about
there what do you say to that person
yeah fantastic so there's probably the
levers all day that's right so I so in a
sense it relates to some of the other uh
prescriptions that I have in the book so
I argue for example that I have a whole
chapter titled Life as a playground
right meaning that immerse yourself in
Endless play even when pursuing very
serious things so science the pursuit of
science is the ultimate form of
intellectual play right because when
you're putting together I'm going to
come to the insurance adjusted in a
second when you're putting together a
puzzle of a thousand piece puzzle you're
trying to make all these pieces fit it
well that's what science is right
there's a bunch of variables out there
and I'm trying to find which one causes
which other one which one correlates to
the other or is unrelated to the other
so it's a form of orgiastic cerebral
play so to the end insurance adjuster I
say that perhaps your job doesn't allow
you that creative play Pursuit but then
at night when you finish your job rather
than watching television for the next
five hours maybe sign up for that
Ceramics class that you had always
wanted to take in other words there is
still a way for me to pursue my creative
impulse to immerse myself and play even
though my profession doesn't afford me
that those opportunities
what would you say to the person that's
struggling and I think this is probably
for mostly for the generation or the
several Generations now behind the two
of us
um who are struggling between the
balance between pleasure and happiness
meaning they've grown up where you can
watch porn all day long you can play
video games all day long you can indulge
in whatever it is that you like to do
all day long basically at your phone as
opposed to getting to the purpose
that'll bring you the happiness and I
think I think a huge amount of people
are struggling with that balance
so if I were to answer that using an
endocrinological framework I would say
in a sense your question can be reframed
as the difference between dopamine and
serotonin right the dopamine hits caters
to my pleasure Center so the porn or the
juicy burger is a one-time hit but
that's not existential Bliss right
that's not right so but when I sit down
and I say I am genuinely a happy person
I've got a great family I love my
children I've got great friends I can
text Dave Rubin in a second he's going
to respond uh you know I I read books
all day I am existentially happy so I
think it's really the difference between
short-term hits of dopamine and
long-term serotonin contentment which by
the way is something that we can also
relate
when you're choosing your partner right
many people will confuse you know lust
and the hormones the neural anatomy of
lust that's gonna fade I don't care
whether you're married to a Greek god
Adonis or Beyonce you know there's the
old expression show me a gorgeous woman
and I'll show you a guy who's tired of
having sex with her yeah that also
speaks to the reality that there is a
huge tedium that sets in if all you are
pursuing is short-term pleasure but on
the other hand for me to be able to go
for a walk with my wife and you know
have fun and joke around and so on
that's contentment so that's I think the
difference between the two do you think
a lot of people don't know what they
want in a spouse partly for what you're
saying that they're just looking for
either the sexiest person or whatever
that they just have no idea what their
actual uh what the lanes are what the
barriers are so for example did you see
the story just in the last week or so
about Jonah Hill sending these texts and
his girlfriend did you happen to see
this story yeah I did so he sent out
what I thought were were fairly uh well
said controlled statements about what
his expectations in a relationship were
don't party with your girlfriends uh you
know don't send out naked pictures like
some basic stuff and then he said hey if
this doesn't work for you I'm not not
the right guy now of course everyone
calls him a misogynist and then you know
all the Press is going after him but I
thought how impressive there's someone
actually saying what they want
yes and not not apologizing for it so
two things I'll say so you probably know
the delphic maxim which is know thyself
so that speaks to your point right
because he he knows what's going to be
his
trajectory of happiness and he's saying
this is what I expect and that could
only happen if I know myself but if I'm
going to put the more General point in a
scientific framework there are two when
it comes to the evolutionary mechanisms
of human mating there are two competing
uh if you like maxims there is the birds
of a feather flock together and there is
the Opposites Attract well it may
interest your audience to know that the
overwhelming consensus in the scientific
literature for long-term happiness of a
union is birds of a feather flock
together oh interesting I would have
said it the other way wow I'll tell you
where you might be right if you said the
excitement of a short-term dalliance
right let's go behind the shed and let's
have some you know dopamine hits
metaphorically speaking then if I am
someone who is restrained who sexually
shy who's introverted and you're the
opposite you bring me out of my shell
those things those opposites might
attract and I might actually come away a
lot more enriched by the fact that we're
different but for long-term Union if we
share values if we share life goals if
we share belief systems it's
astoundingly more likely that we'll be
happy so what Jonah Hill was doing was
being a perfect darwinian being and
recognizing that he wants someone who
shares his values there's nothing wrong
with that
right I wonder if in some ways there's
sort of like a big picture little
picture version of that because I always
find like if I was to look at me and
David for example we really agree on all
the big picture stuff of what we've
wanted out of life and build things
together and that's why you know
thankfully it's it knock on wood it's
worked and it's growing and all that but
we're very different in another we're
opposites when it comes to attention to
detail organization all of those things
so I guess there's probably a couple
different layers of all of this that's
why when I was referring to birds of a
feather flock together I specifically
said what those criteria are that we
should match on we're not trying to
match on our eye color we're not trying
to match on our the morphology of our
faces it's life goals it's life mindsets
it's belief systems that's what we're
talking about birds of feather flock
together incidentally on physicality by
the way there is one trait that we also
have assorted of mating and that's on
height so that if you look at naturally
occurring couples I'm talking about
heterosexual couples but we could easily
extend it to same-sex couples
there was a study that was done with 720
actual couples one of which one out of
720 that it violate the the assortative
cue of male should be taller than female
so that's a very important cue the only
the only true well this doesn't bode
well for uh say Ben Shapiro
oh his wife is taller I'm not sure
exactly but you know I was just trying
to think of somebody that's not known as
well I'm not exactly breaking the seven
foot Mark but I'm taller than my wife
that's the most important thing so so in
other words uh it's not so much that men
have to be taller than a you know than
six feet I mean yeah that's nice but
it's that you certainly don't want to be
with someone who is uh taller than you
and that's why if you're a tall if
you're a tall educated woman your
chances of finding a right man are
really precipitously decreased because
if you're a six foot two woman
you're very unlikely to want a shorter
guy while there are very fewer men who
are six foot three and more now if
you're very educated as a woman you you
almost never want someone who is of
lesser educational status so now you
have to find the six foot four PhD good
luck with that
what do you make of how people now go
about finding that spouse where
everybody's flipping on apps and doing
all that stuff where we've sort of
atomized all of the traits that you
might actually after in the old days go
out with somebody and figure out now by
the time you sit down with them at that
restaurant you know what movies they
like you know what music they like you
you found out all of these quirks so
we've
compartmentalized all of these things
that are about the exploration right
right yeah and actually I've done
several I've published several uh
academic studies looking at sex
differences in information search within
the mating domain right and what I have
found and even in an online medium using
actual you know computer software to
track how many pieces of information you
look at so here's an interesting piece
of information
when it comes to rejection data what I
mean by rejection data I mean how much
information do men and women need to
look at before they've seen enough to
reject potential suitors well women
require a lot less evidence to reject
mates on the other hand when it comes to
choosing data meaning when have I looked
at enough information to now be
satisfied that I'm ready to choose
whomever then women search for more
information now that makes perfect
evolutionary sense because there's the
something called the parental investment
Theory which basically argues that if
you want to understand which of the two
sexes in a species is going to be more
sexually choosy you have to look at
which of the two sexes
has the the the the the greater amount
of minimal parental obligatory
investment and for most species it is
females who have the the greater minimal
parental investment therefore it looms
much larger for them to make an
erroneous mate search that's why they
have to be more judicious in their mate
searches so there's a great song by the
way from the 70s you might know it
called uh uh why why don't why do the
girls get all prettier at closing time
or something it's a do you know that
song that it's not totally sure we'll
see if we can grab a little sample it
actually it was what led to an act to a
study I think it was in 1975 uh country
song basically what it was arguing if I
couch it in evolutionary language that
you know men
when they go to the bar at 10 at night
they only want to have sex with the
supermodel at 12 o'clock she could be at
seven on ten at three o'clock in the
morning as long as she doesn't have a
tail and horns and she still has a pulse
we're good to go meaning that men relax
the their threshold of acceptability as
the night of loneliness Looms in the
background but you don't see that the
other way around right there is no song
that's been written called don't the
guys get more handsome near closing time
because of making a wrong choice Loom as
large whether it's at 10 in the morning
or three in the 10 in the afternoon or
three in the morning for women and so I
discuss all of these things actually in
the happiness book when it comes to mate
search
are you surprised how many people are
not happy I mean you know we've been
blessed to travel in some pretty great
circles and you know I know plenty of
people that I think are at least roughly
happy or trying to do something decent
but I know a decent amount of miserable
people that have an awful lot in terms
of what you would think are the pieces
that make you happy uh oh you're
absolutely right I mean I we see it on
Twitter right I mean I you know I was
away I was away for 16 days in Portugal
and so I only posted you know beach
photos I didn't weigh in on anything so
I was still posting things but never
checking anything and I I didn't check
what my blood pressure was pre and post
but I'm almost certain there was a huge
Improvement because I wasn't exposed to
the endless misery of people right and
and you know me well Dave even when I'm
going after someone even when I am you
know insulting them in some
spicy way I always do it I I hope so
with you know with a playful mindset so
it does actually amaze me that people
can be so miserable now I wonder
and when here I'm speculating but I I
think there is value in what I'm saying
here I wonder if the fact that I I had
my childhood history I mean you know it
but maybe some of you are listed right I
mean I I'm a product of the Lebanese
Civil War
so notwithstanding that I have a sunny
disposition the fact that I've seen some
of the truly horrible things of Life
maybe that even adds to my ability to be
happy because every time I find the
reason to be pissed off at something I
can easily insert that voice in my head
that says you could have not gotten out
of Lebanon in 1975. so why don't you
stop your whining this is my internal
voice and just go out there and
appreciate life so I think in in some
interesting way the fact that I've had
to face these anti-fragile stressors in
my childhood allows me to be that much
happier in my day-to-day and maybe those
Twitter miserable people they need to go
to uh rakka Syria and see how people
live there and then maybe there won't be
such miserable cretans what advice would
you give for people on the social media
front in that regard you know I do my
August Off the Grid which this will be
my seventh year of doing it I I think it
actually
is one of the things that has kept me
happy insane and clear-minded throughout
all this and I I didn't lose my mind
during covid and I didn't lose my mind
during Trump or any of those well I
guess that's for other people to judge
but ballpark I think I I kind of made it
out okay
um but that's social media which of
course the word social is in there were
social creatures it's designed to make
us social but it actually seemingly made
us more and more anti-social more
neurotic and fearful of strangers and
all sorts of stuff
well maybe I could answer this in it by
drawing an analogy to you know we are a
storytelling animal so we we often learn
best not by having sort of academic
abstract ideas but by contextualizing it
with a story so to those social media
you know Sullen folks listen to these
two stories so in the in the last
chapter of uh the sad truth about
happiness I discussed two powerful
stories that capture the mindset that is
the antithesis of those people on social
media so two stories number one
arguably the most incredible
conversation I've had on my show and
that's saying a lot because just like
you I've had I've been fortunate enough
to speak to all sorts of incredible
people is a gentleman by the name of
David McCallum whom you probably don't
know who that is David McCallum is
someone who spent 29 years in prison for
a murder that he was eventually
exonerated I think he went into prison
at uh 17 years old and he came out well
into her his 40s and as we were chatting
on the show
I looked at him and you can go watch our
chat it's really quite powerful I said
to him you know I'm amazed David I mean
you must be a Reincarnation of Buddha
because I'm amazed that you're not
filled with vengefulness with
vindictiveness with anger you're a much
better man than I am because if I had
been in your position and if 30 29 years
had been stolen from me I would want to
burn the world down and then his answer
so to speak to those social media people
who you know go crazy about every little
thing he said you know I have a a sister
who's been bedridden with cerebral palsy
for much of her life and yet she still
finds time to smile and be grateful for
what she has and so viewed from that
perspective I don't really have much to
be angry about I mean that's an
incredibly powerful story second guy
that I'll tell you about is uh is a
gentleman whom I met so when I was a
professor at University of California
Irvine I was sitting at a cafe in
Newport Beach you know working on some
paper or whatever and I had a whole
bunch of books all over the table and
this gentleman comes up says oh I'm your
lovely collection of books you've got
here do you mind if I sit with you and
chat it turned out that he was a PhD
student at UC Irvine completing his his
doctoral dissertation on studying uh
homelessness he had immersed himself
within the homeless Community to learn
more about sort of their ecosystem and
eventually he became homeless himself so
that and he was a wealthy Persian guy so
he came from money he had a lot of money
and then several years later he became a
homeless guy well I tracked him down
there's an article that I cite in the
book from 2011. so this is about 10
years after we had met where someone is
asking him are you are you happy are you
sad how do you deal with what's happened
in your life and his answer again is a
good answer to those social media
selling people he's said I've got access
to a gym where I can keep my body
healthy I've got access to the Newport
Beach Library so I can keep my mind uh
nourished I've got nothing to be angry
or sad about those are powerful stories
so to those people who go crazy about
Trump and so on there's such a bigger
world out there
there is such misery out there be
grateful can I tell you something that
just popped in my head as you were
telling that story I have not thought
about this for probably 20 years I'm not
kidding you but when I was in my mid-20s
and I was messed up because I was
closeted and you know struggling stand
up and I had no money all of that stuff
I used to stand on the corners in Times
Square handing out tickets to get people
to come to the shows that's how you get
stage time and there was this homeless
guy out there his name was Charlie
because he was always panhandling while
we were handing out tickets and I always
used to think it's kind of funny I'm
basically doing the same thing as a
homeless guy but Charlie had the biggest
freaking smile on his face all the time
which I very specifically remember
because his teeth were horribly mangled
and everything else but always was
smiling joking around with everybody he
had a very funny sign about how he was
gonna uh he said I'm not gonna
you I'm just gonna spend the money on
booze and weed but come on why not and
he was just funny and I remember
thinking that homeless man is happier
than me and that is one of the things
that started turning me around because I
thought I have every opportunity in this
world this guy has none and I I truly
have not thought about that for 20 some
odd years and that just sparked out of
me I'm glad that it triggered that look
right now I'm going I've started my big
tour for as a media thing for you for
the book and so you know this weekend I
was looking at my entire schedule oh my
god I've got to travel here I got to do
this and then I stopped I said am I
really whining about the fact that I've
got all these opportunities and I have a
book coming out
F off guard side and so so if you've got
if you've got that internal voice of
authenticity you're always able to snap
yourself back into into the right
mindset yeah what are some of the other
tricks that that people can use if
they're really in a funk you know when
somebody when you're in those moments in
life that you're just tripped up family
problems money problems you're doing the
job you don't want to do like the whole
thing seems like it's off you have some
tricks that can kind of just get someone
going because it seems like that first
step is often the biggest hurdle I
actually so I have a whole chapter so it
speaks partially to the question you're
asking uh I have a whole chapter on sort
of how can you minimize regret in life
because regret in a sense is that
existential you know voice that keeps
coming in your head that makes you think
what if what if I've done this what I
what if I've done that right and so many
of us think that opportunities for
happiness have passed us by we're too
old to be let's say I know that you love
the NBA well that is true that is
objectively true it would be silly for
you or I to think about being NBA stars
although you have seen some of my
three-point shots yeah so maybe I can
still make it plus we have had some good
back and forth that's right that's right
but no but seriously uh there are many
cases where that sense of I can't get
out of this funk is is sort of a
deterministic doom whereas in reality
you've placed this restriction in your
so let me give you two again two
examples
example one uh this is from in the book
there's a gentleman who left a pre-nazi
Germany he was a Jewish guy left and
came to Canada had always wanted to
study and you know get a university
education but life circumstances didn't
allow him to he comes to Canada as a
young kid uh goes to work has a
successful career retires in his 60s
hit now he's in his 60s right I mean
average undergrad is 20 19. he says you
know what I'm now I'm of good mind I
have time why don't I sign up he
actually went to the university that I
work with uh at and he said why don't I
sign up and take some undergraduate
courses lo and behold a few years later
he finishes his undergrad then he says
hey I'm still young I'm now in my 70s
why don't I pursue my Master's Degree
finishes it and then in his 80s starts
his PhD and I remember this was in 1996
it was very early in my academic career
the the University newspaper had the
title something like finally a doctor at
91 and so he finishes his PhD and within
a year he passes away so he could have
easily said I you know I missed my
opportunity to study well no you had an
opportunity to do it and you did it
second example I just had this guy last
year on my show
this is a physician who got I think his
medical degree at University of Vienna
in 1955 then while he was training to be
a hematologist as a specialist picked up
a PhD in 1967. you weren't born yet I
was two years old two and a half years
old
but he had always wanted to be a
physicist his real love was physics but
his family had told him Jewish guy you
have to do something practical become a
physician blah blah blah and he did it
at the age of 89 he completed a second
PhD in physics at Brown University so
why am I telling you these again these
stories because oftentimes we're in a
funk because we place these arbitrary
illusory barriers in our minds yes we
can't be future NBA stars we're too old
for that we can't be ballerinas we're
not going to be Maestro violinists but
for many other things that would make us
happy it's only our inner voice that's
stopping us from doing so get off the
couch and go do it
can you be too happy do you think I mean
we all know the person that just kind of
lives in the clouds that may be smiling
all the time but really isn't on the
ball or basically isn't on planet Earth
Lex Friedman sorry I had something stuck
in my well he's not really not that I
wanted to talk about him but he and I
argue he engages in full happiness right
he's always I love you you love me let's
hug I think what was his what was his
tweet a couple weeks ago that everybody
went crazy on I think you really nailed
him on wasn't there something uh too
long ago whether you call yourself male
or female I care about what your
character is or something like that and
and that pissed me off now again people
think when I go after someone I'm trying
to be me I'm not and that's because
there's a part of me that's a dogged
Defender Of Truth and actually I talk
about this in the book that existential
authenticity is a sure Pathway to
happiness right I present myself to the
world as though I'm 18 feet tall because
I'm always authentic I really know my
qualities I know my faults I don't
modulate anything and so there are no
fisters in my my personhood and that's
why I then can feel comfortable in any
setting because I've got nothing to I
don't have to retain lies It For Better
or Worse here I am and and what I was
pissed with Lex is that is you know I
didn't know who Lex was frankly but then
people said oh you should go on his show
that's how I started getting to know him
and then I would see all this inane
that he would consistently post
and it just pissed me off so in his case
I don't know if he's being real or not
he he has gone into the extra happiness
because not everything in life is about
hugging and happiness right I mean uh
that's a false narrative and that's why
I tried to go after him and now to his
lack of credit he always says oh I
always am willing to learn from anyone
and speak to anyone first thing he does
is he blocks me what a schmuck foreign
so you can be happy and still think
someone's a schmuck that's good that
should definitely exactly right and by
the way to to that point people often
say to me oh when they meet me oh you
seem so much nicer and friendlier than
on social media no because this is
called situational specificity right if
you attack me in a in an alley I might
be violent because you're trying to mug
me that's not because I'm
dispositionally violent it's because I
act differently when I'm tucking my
children to bed and when I'm being
mugged in an alley so when I am being
mugged by on social media I act
in a spicier manner not because I'm not
happy or I'm mean or I'm it's because
different strategies require different
approaches I mean or different contexts
so you're a little happier when you're
basically putting your kids to sleep
than you are when you're being mugged I
just want to make sure I got that one
clean that is that is a correct
statement indeed what about uh the
things that people at least give get the
temporary happiness on whether it might
be the uh the booze or the extra
Indulgence in food or whatever they
might be smoking or the other stuff
completely fleeting so I talk about in
the book as a as someone who studies
consumer psychology right so I wanted to
link it to some of my own interests so
there's been now several studies that
I've looked at whether spending money on
material possessions so that speaks to
kind of your point right should I get
the next product bag or the really cool
Gucci or the Maserati whether spend what
brings you greater long-term happiness
the spending on money on material
possessions or on experiences and
overwhelmingly repeatedly the research
shows that for long-term enduring
happiness living a life of Rich
experiences is going to bring you a lot
more bang for the buck than if you spend
it on Ferrari and I know this from
personal experience because one of my
brothers who until recently lived in
Southern California and was very very
wealthy during the.com era he had not
one not two but three Ferraris he had an
Aston Martin lagunda he had also he was
a collector of conspicuous consumption
Goods uh I hate to say it and I don't
say this with any Glee uh I don't think
today he's happy right whereas I never
drove a Ferrari I never had access to a
Ferrari but later today my children are
going to come and are going to say oh
how was your chat with Dave Rubin that
moment right there is probably makes me
wealthier than all of his Ferraris put
together
when you get to the happiness part part
so the place that you're basically at in
your life at this moment
um do you have to keep doing work to
sustain it or at that point if you feel
like you got it right you can just kind
of write it out I mean do you feel like
there are things on the horizon Beyond
you have to keep doing your work keep
maintaining that good relationship is
there anything else you got to do to
really keep pushing forward well I think
yeah the amazing question I think you'll
have to keep implementing those
strategies that ensure that you are
going to remain happy that if I were to
analogize it if I now get off my very
obsessive uh weight concerns it won't
take me long before we get two times God
again right in other words it won't take
I mean I mean literally no I have to say
I have to say God two times weight Gad
pretty happy he was pretty happy as far
as yourself pretty happy although my
blood pressure was not as happy uh
although my physician was not as happy
with me so so again I think from the
perspective of extending my happiness as
far as I can go literally in terms of
life expectancy and contrary to what
Professor Dr lizzo tells us uh you know
you know you know what I'm talking about
yes I got it lizzo she's uh they're
fortifying the stage therefore I find
the stage and she argues that you know
stop talking about this nonsense about
health being related to your weight
that's just the construct uh my life
expectancy knock on wood is hopefully
going to you know drastically increase
by virtue of you know my having now been
be it the right weight but I have to
always be uh careful right and so to to
your point about happiness I don't think
you can get to mouth happiness to the
summit and say I've done it all now let
me take crystal meth and I will continue
to be happy you still have to work on
your relationships you still have to be
playful you still have to nourish your
mind all those things are Perpetual
Pursuits
God watch very closely the screen right
now because I'm going to wink at you as
I ask you this question
can you mindfully meditate yourself into
happiness
[Laughter]
audience will know what I just asked and
some will not it's okay yes as a matter
of fact so in one of the chapters I'm
gonna come to your mindful meditation in
a second in one of the chapters
I talk about the fundamentally most
powerful law in nature which is what I
call the inverted U curve inverted U
which the ancient Greek Greeks already
knew about is too little of something is
not good too much of something is not
good and The Sweet Spot is somewhere in
the middle which Aristotle referred to
as the golden mean which Buddha referred
to as the middle way maimonides refer to
it and so in that chapter I demonstrate
that across a bewildering number of
contexts that inverted you applies
including to mindful meditation meaning
that if you never are mindful in terms
of meditating or taking a deep breath or
something it's not good but doing it too
much it's not good and actually that
speaks to a tweet that I think Elon Musk
Elon Musk said had sent to that person
in question saying so and so there is
such a thing as too much meditation so
that exactly speaks to your point always
find the middle way The Sweet Spot
you'll be happier
again I have to say one of my great joys
in life is that I I think I found the
spouse I was supposed to find we'll put
that one aside but the other one that
I'm doing the work that I'm supposed to
be doing and that it has allowed me to
have friendships like I have with you
because we've done this it seems like a
long time but it ain't that long but but
we both somehow uh still managed to do
this with a smile on our face and uh to
Traverse some new ground and that's why
it's a pleasure oh he's talking to you
my friend you're at the light Big E hug
and I hope to see you in Florida soon
what else can I offer you Freedom low
taxes the weather's great you'll keep
this hand I mean what what am I doing
here give me you're okay with sweating
give me some ten years to replace my
tenured professorship
give me tenure or give me death that
could be your next book
the book is happiness eight secrets for
leading the good life
God said is leading a good life good to
see you my friend thank you Dave so good
to talk to you cheers if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about Academia check out
our Academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell